I think I'm his biggest fan I just like
being with her it's always fun for me
the couple that prays together stays
together
anytime I can be around Blake is you
know and I witnessed lzt that Gwen
Stefani and Blake Shelton attended
church together on Saturday night in
Beverly Hills they brought Gwen's kids
along Kingston Zuma and Apollo I love it
according to the eyewitness the couple
embraced the majority of the time and
seemed very much in love quote they all
seemed very happy and content
Gwen sang along with the hymns while
Blake was spotted sharing some jokes
with her boys it's incredible to have a
best friend like that guy he's an
amazing person come on man this is this
is romance around here the couple
started dating in 2015 after they were
both coaches on the voice after taking a
few seasons off Gwen is making her way
back to the big red chair for the
upcoming new season replacing Adam
Levine who announced his departure from
the show in May hey Blake what a girl
fan sitting next to me he sat down with
the country star in July where he opened
up about being competitive with his
ladylove at the end of the day it
wouldn't it's no different than if win
and I were playing you know cards or you
know any kind of game you know she wants
to win and I want to win that's what
they pay us to do on this show is to try
to win the show so it's harder for her
she's not she's not competitive she'll
be the first to tell you right up until
it gets competitive and then all of a
sudden if she is I couldn't be happier
that she's back on the show
[Music]